es tiempo de hablar de economía quien
france24 y estamos para eso con daniela
blandón nuestra periodista experta que
nos va a contar lo más importante hoy
daniela bienvenida en el banco central
de argentina y puso nuevas restricciones
a la compra legal de dólares cuéntanos
un poco daniela liliana muy buenas
noches mire eso es conocido como el cepo
cambiario que es diseñado para proteger
la fuga de reservas de divisas lo que
hace el gobierno es restringir cada vez
más el acceso a los dólares ya existe un
cupo de 200 dólares mensuales para cada
ciudadano pero lo nuevo es que dentro de
ese cupo van a estar todas las compras
que se hagan con divisas y con tarjetas
por ejemplo liliana de ese como usted se
gasta 100 dólares comprando con la
tarjeta de crédito o débito pues ese
cupo se le reduce a 100 dólares al mes
pero si se pasa es decir compra mil
dólares en el mes usted estaría
absorbiendo el cupo de los siguientes
cinco meses y en este periodo no podrá
comprar más dólares pero eso no es todo
por esos gastos se pagará un 35 por
ciento de impuestos que se suma a otro
30% que se había decretado a finales de
2019 escuchemos
lo que hace es incrementar en un 35% el
valor de todas las compras que se
realizan en una extranjera como así
también para la adquisición de los 200
dólares que tenemos como tope en la
argentina
por persona para adquirir de esta manera
de alguna forma se está aumentando de
manera indirecta
el tipo de cambio al que tenemos acceso
y eso tiene repercusión directa en los
precios y estamos hablando solamente del
llamado dólar oficial porque recordemos
liliana que en argentina existe casi una
decena de tipos de dólares distintos
desde el blog que se consigue en el
mercado informal pasando por el soja el
cereal el liquid y muchos otros hasta
incluso el dólar netflix que se usa para
pagar este tipo de servicios y todos con
un precio diferente interesante daniela
la reserva federa anunció que dejará la
tasa de interés quieta para estimular la
economía esto quiere decir que se
mantienen en 0%
pero además el banco central de eeuu
hizo una nueva y audaz promesa y es que
las va a mantener allí por un buen
tiempo al menos hasta 2023 la tarea de
los bancos centrales es jugar con las
tasas de interés para fomentar empleos
pero sin perder de vista la inflación lo
que decidió hacer fue jugársela toda por
el empleo así tenga que descuidar un
poco esos precios de la canasta familiar
de esta manera cree que podrá lograr que
la tasa de desempleo baje al 7,6 por
ciento a finales
por otro lado la fed mejoró la
proyección de pib para 2020 y ya no
espera una caída del 65 por ciento sino
del 37 bueno daniela y la ocde también
mejor sus previsiones pero sobre la
economía mundial si la organización para
la cooperación y el desarrollo económico
dijo que la crisis no será tan dramática
como la que se esperaba hace tres meses
en esa línea ahora espera que el pib
mundial caiga 45 por ciento y no 6% como
proyectaba en junio en lo que sí es más
pesimista es en la recuperación pues
para 2021 bajó un poco su pronóstico y
lo dejó en 5 por ciento de crecimiento
en lo que se hizo énfasis fue en las
enormes pérdidas económicas que tendrá
toda esta crisis que fue será de unos 7
millones de dólares bueno considera de
todas formas daniela y la curiosidad del
día y si concluyó la famosa rifa del
avión presidencial de mexico como para
todo este tema
para liliana lo más curioso de la
curiosidad es que la rifa no era
precisamente del jet presidencial de
lujo que todavía está aparcado esperando
que les resulte un pretendiente sino de
su equivalente
en una transmisión por televisión fueron
sorteados entre 6 millones de boletas
los 100 felices ganadores cada uno de 20
millones de pesos mexicanos o por un
poco menos de un millón de dólares lo
que no se sabe es cuántos de ellos
fueron las clínicas a las que el
gobierno les invirtió un buen dinero en
regalarles cientos de boletas justamente
los recursos que se obtuvieron con este
sorteo van a ser destinados según el
gobierno a la compra de equipos médicos
que tanto se necesitan ahora en plena
pandemia bueno un poco confuso el tema
no angelo porque no se sabe finalmente
quién se va a quedar con la plata con el
avión pero bueno vamos con los
indicadores de la jornada
bueno iniciamos hoy en américa latina'
con el desplome de más del 5 por ciento
en la bolsa de buenos aires pues a los
inversionistas no les gustó para nada
las medidas anunciadas para restringir
el acceso a los dólares wall street' por
su parte cerró mixto sin grandes cambios
a pesar de la expectativa que había por
la reunión de la fed que concluyó hoy y
en europa las plazas bursátiles subieron
con una excepción de londres en donde
hay mucha expectativa sobre cómo va a
terminar pues ésta
por la información de economía y usted
gracias continue ve con más en nuestra
página web france24 puntos cuando vemos
más adelante
i